foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
we are
amazing welcome to to the father State
YouTube live I'm Jesse Lee Peterson
apologize for the late straw but we are
black and black people are late
we start our CP time I'm glad you're
here you love me I don't really know you
do you have to know me to love me yeah
well I love you thank you are you
surprised not really were you surprised
that I threw you off the radio show
not really and one of the reasons I'm
concerned about you being a progressive
is that me specifically or all
progressives all men men only men only
men Progressive women don't concern it's
normal normal abnormal for women to be
Progressive interesting oh a liberal but
it's abnormal for a man to be a liberal
or Progressive is a sign of being a beta
male I didn't know we call real men are
conservative if I became conservative
would I no longer be beta
you become Alpha well
something to think about do you find
that it's difficult for young men merely
your age group to find good women to
date not at all right why don't you date
men I'm not attracted to men oh good
what would you considered it might be a
man would you think of it as a man it
would I think of it as a man right
it's a person right I don't say it right
it's a female the children are rely on
the liberal media the Democratic party
the writer Republicans the never
trumpers okay uh so like everybody but
Trump the hashtag movement plus you see
someone mentally off you know like like
the life was all but nobody was home
you're making assessments of who's
mentally off on TV but that's how evil
the children of the left are they'll
destroy you to get what they want and
that's power and wealth I'm curious if
they're so powerful the children of the
life they're not powerful oh that's what
they want I think they will destroy you
they will they'll destroy you they'll
try to destroy you oh okay to get power
do you agree with that no no we're
bringing that up the reason was you've
called me a girly man so many times
remember that we talked about the week
oh okay that's because it's not because
I think you that I'm gay right
got it glad we clarified you know a lot
of people are sexually assaulted and
raped and they don't come forward and
the reason
you don't believe that that's a made-up
line too oh who made that up the
children are the left I should I'm sure
they're doing it because they hate men
oh and they especially hate straight
white Conservative Christian men of
power if it wasn't for them America
would be a socialist society already it
would be what a socialist society by
getting rid of jobs many people mostly
took care of people about getting rid of
full-time jobs and they had to work two
part-time jobs in order to survive so
you don't even understand the talking
points free Obama phones
that's the answer but I don't like the
answer you don't understand the question
I think I understand it uh what what is
it about the question that's difficult
for you do you would you David Pac-Man
believe it just because she said it I
liked how you had to check what my last
name was there
I wouldn't believe it enough to
investigate it yeah
give me just a yes sir I'm black and
slow so give me a simple yes or no your
friends are watching right now I hope so
and they're watching because they
thought you're gonna keep my butt so you
got to live up to it I found out this
was a debate today would you believe it
are these really the most important
topics for you absolutely okay are there
others that are more important for you
yeah our economic system wealth
inequality Health Care politics nuclear
disarmament climate change and the black
people go into a trance
and they go in and they just yeah they
they reach for the D while eating
chicken I guarantee you if they went now
and voted for and asked them to vote for
it they'll go with the homosexuals I
hope so and the Democratic party they
have been morally bankrupt well I just
radical homosexuals have got in there
and corrupted churches and so anything
else not that I can think of that's it
yeah amazing people coming from [ __ ]
countries and we don't have no idea who
crossing the borders uh we could have
Bin Laden folks coming I think we just
disagree amazing
um
it's crazy to disagree isn't it is that
a good thing that the president has done
what did he do worry about jobs how it
doesn't matter how he's brought them
back is that a good thing if you're
going to claim he did it you have to
explain how is that a good thing that
happened because there are two new jobs
the question is what did he do to bring
the jobs
can you identify what he did I just told
you man how do you know how you did it
and this is a good thing that he did or
not jobs are good I'm asking you what
Trump did what are you saying yesterday
what is a man I'm sorry what is a man
I do politics not dictionary are you a
man love What is love
I I don't do dictionary definitions I
won't be doing dictionary definitions at
any of my events that's the one thing if
people are expecting that I'm not doing
any dictionary definitions
they're so amazing it's incredible you
like celebs I'm sorry your life less I
don't know any have you ever said that
with a [ __ ] I don't think so would you
date a [ __ ]
it's a pejorative it's not a term I use
amazing did you have fun no in in a
thousand years when the sociologists and
the philosophers try to figure out what
exactly happened in the United States
right around this time this type of
conversation is going to be incredibly
informative for them so I'm glad
yes it was amazing check out our brand
new song on the uh Destiny peterson.com
on my Instagram
um you're doing songs now huh
Facebook Twitter yeah sing are you
playing Instagram
you know what a beta mail is
no check out the song cheers Trump right
Alpha
not beta see him with the toilet paper
on his shoe super Alpha move huh I
didn't see it but
Apple thank you
thank you all thank you thank you all
right
mangoes
[Music]
now that we are up under our body's
regime my bag of mangoes now cost eleven
dollars and
[Music]
99.8 or 11 bucks
[Music]
[Music]
all right
[Music]
the Wisconsin crowd identified
[Applause]
the American people
don't want me to me
it's highway robbery is what you doing
[Music]
welcome everybody I legitimately crack
up at some of those songs every time I
uh I watch those videos great to see
everybody Welcome uh things have changed
so quickly and this is exactly the point
I made on Twitter this morning that the
title stock market collapses is no
longer appropriate because of what
happened in the final half hour of
trading today and this is exactly the
point I was making people sell
everything bear Market until March at
least well maybe or maybe not I don't
pretend to know so with all do
permission sir ma'am I'm just gonna wait
and see and hold I'm not gonna do any
crazy selling
I'm not gonna do any crazy buying I'm
just gonna hold because I don't think
you know what's gonna happen and I know
I don't know what's going to happen and
this applies to crypto
this applies to uh stocks
this applies to bonds
um we're gonna make that uh the next
piece of this but welcome everybody I
have so many things to offer you today
and I hope you will accept some of them
with peace and love I will be
adjudicating some unbanned requests I
will be playing some voicemails we're
going to be looking at some classic uh
elements of uh internet culture and
history
um so many different things but we may
be heading in the direction
we may be heading in the direction of
War
although I really hope not but it's
starting to get very very hectic when it
comes to Russia and Ukraine
first and foremost wait a second where
am I here we go Pentagon puts why are
things off screen there's no I thought I
had it all set up correctly
hold on a second let's see if we can fix
this folks
let me see what we can do
ah there we go beautiful
okay Pentagon puts 8 500 troops on
heightened alert as U.S ways military
action against Russia among the options
presented to the president was to move
troops and equipment from other parts of
Europe into Poland Romania and other
countries neighboring Ukraine
this is a response to what I believe
based on satellite imagery and
trustworthy reporting Russia amassing
troops at the border with Ukraine there
are Marxist stalinist leninist
revolutionary leftists
who will say it's all made up
it's all made up none of it's happening
it's the imperialists who want to
I don't know what okay uh remember
Ukraine not a NATO member at this point
in time and that is a big subject of
controversy
uh but there is a lot Happening Here
U.S is discussing deployment of forces
to Eastern Europe with NATO allies
8 500 troops on heightened alert to
assist with the defense of NATO allies
Pentagon spokesman John Kirby said I
want to reinforce that as of now the
decision has been made to put these
units on higher alert and higher alert
only
no decisions have been made to deploy
forces from the U.S at this time this
time
with Moscow massing more than 100 000
troops at its neighbor's border and no
diplomatic breakthrough in sight the
West is stepping up its response and
mounting fears amid mounting fears and
Invasion could be imminent should I
issue my um
non-imperialist
disclaimers here because anytime I go
anywhere near these topics next thing
you know there will be like minor
YouTube channels and obscure Twitter
accounts
saying David Pacman is rallying for war
and regime change everywhere
what
what no I am not rallying for that and
in fact I don't want there to be
military conflict why because I'm
selfish I want things to be calm calm is
better for the stock market calm is
better for the economy calm is better
for travel flights Etc
I guess should I mention I would prefer
there be no war like do I even need to
say that seems like I have to clarify
all this stuff globalished
internationalist trotskyite socialist
unlike Obama Trudeau mccrone and the
rest of these Zio beasts
yeah
um okay so that's that's taking place
CNN report NATO allies put forces on
standby as tensions rise
as I've said before I still do I don't
pretend to know whether Putin is really
going to invade or not it's kind of like
when when people make predictions about
something that could go either way and
whether your prediction is right or not
doesn't mean you knew anything it's sort
of like I predict you know I predict Tom
Brady is going to come back even though
they're down 14 and they're going to win
and then if it doesn't happen it's like
look you were wrong and if it happens
like wow you were right what we just
didn't know is a prediction about a
future event an unknown future event
Putin may be massing troops at the
border to generate exactly this reaction
and to then gamify it or weaponize it in
some way
Putin may be doing this because he has a
plan to invade and if he has a plan to
invade there's a real question as to
what does he believe is the long term of
that is it to try to force NATO's hand
in some way is it you know there's all
of the I don't pretend to know what
Putin actually has planned I think it
could be either
um
oh yeah I guess so that's another thing
that I no matter what happens
Republicans will say Biden is being weak
in his response they'll talk out of both
sides of their mouths they'll say
Russia's great and with Trump we were
getting along with Russia and we should
get along with Russia and Biden was so
weak in responding to Putin's aggression
what a weak beta it's like well hold on
did you what what did you what huh
it will make no sense whatsoever
it will make no sense and uh that you
can
that you can bet on no matter what Biden
does the right will say it's a sign of
uh of weakness quite frankly all right
so that's what's going on with Russia
Ukraine we're going to have a bigger
report
on that for you tomorrow uh Lucian says
via Super Chat David sir no hold on
sir sir David sir do you think Romania
as a neighbor NATO country should be
worried about being attacked by Russia
as a Romanian I am worried I don't
believe so
based on everything I've read so far and
I'm glad for people you know if people
have other opinions I do not believe
people in Romania need to be worried
Larry says much love David and friends
just got my data mail shirt and excited
to rock it in public keep up the
incredible work thanks Larry I um I I
really appreciate that thank you very
much before we move on to the next thing
and I have a I have an OP I haven't
um an offer for someone in the audience
to make a little bit of money
I'm going to make that uh I'm going to
talk about that in a moment
um
oh wait this is funny Brandon says as a
Marxist leninist bidenist I believe we
should invade Russia for dissolving the
USSR right that's like when it goes full
circle that's really a beautiful example
David sir could you give an official
rating on war on a scale of one to ten
if War uh my rating of War
if one is really bad and 10 means war is
grade I rate War a one I think war is
bad guys it's really bad really really
bad I don't like War
um okay
ah yes I want to thank the following
people for supporting us via twitch K
shreds jalter corefi Jimmy Ten Pins gen
gifting two
uh that's six Harry liquid ice
merkelist and Ja Chrissy that's ten oh
my God I don't even have my widget
hold on a second where on Earth is my
widget
uh
here it is oh my God and it started at
23. what what a unprofessional stream
there we go now we're good now we're at
10. also thanks to Green Man
for 23 months over on Twitch and uh feel
free to sign up on my website
joinpakman.com the coupon code Obama
still gives you a big discount Obama
okay let's go to the next thing I have
an opportunity wait we're not doing that
yet hold on where is it
ah here it is here's an opportunity for
someone to make a little bit of money
and I'm going to ask you guys what this
should pay here is my request here's my
request this Saturday Donald Trump is
doing another rally this one is in
Conroe Texas I believe that's the it's
not cornrow right it's Conroe contextens
confirm
anybody and we will ban men Conroe Texas
okay the rally is in Conroe Texas this
Saturday it's at the Montgomery
County Fairgrounds
schedule
what time is prompt seven o'clock I
believe I assume that this is seven
Texas time meaning eight eastern time
okay I want someone from my audience to
go to the rally if you feel comfortable
with outdoor covet exposure
and interview people live so while I'm
streaming we would connect with you via
Skype or Google meet or somehow we would
do it I would even feed you questions so
we could talk to the trumpists okay
here's the thing
We're Not Gonna Fly anyone there like
it's got to be you've got to live nearby
and be able to get there and you need to
figure out how to get into the rally so
I I know that you know one option is
just get a ticket to the rally I know
Trump pretends these are hot hot tickets
and you know they're sold out or
whatever the tickets are free if you can
get a ticket or register as media or try
both I don't know exactly the best way
to get there and you've got to bring
your own equipment okay and we just want
like 45 minutes or so of you talking to
people and I will have some questions
for them that's the gist of it okay that
that's the whole plan so if anybody's
interested in that you've got to email
me info davidpackman.com
and tell me how close you live and you
know whether you'd go alone or bring
someone to film or whatever you know
give me give me some sense like if you
email me and you say I don't know that I
have the right equipment it's like I'm
you're not the right candidate you know
be confident that with your iPhone you
can do it or whatever you've got you
gotta really understand it and
as I said it is I am not asking anyone
to do this for free can people in the
chat tell me what I should pay for this
it's not a cross-country trip you should
live nearby like no further than an hour
or so you know hour an hour and a half
what should what should I pay 350 one
person says
15 per hour no no no no no it's gonna be
a flat fee it's going to be a flat fee
a thousand dollars this is Saturday in
Conroe Texas
uh some people saying a million dollars
a billion 1500
what do people want five a lot of five
hundreds
fifteen thousand a hundred bucks a
hundred bucks seems low
at least seven dollars
10 Bitcoin
I mean I'm thinking about 500 bucks
seems something in the neighborhood of
500 bucks for for 45 minutes of talking
to people if you live nearby I mean
maybe you know it's maybe a couple hours
500 is seeming reasonable ish
500 plus gas maybe yeah I mean listen
it's in the ballpark it's in the
ballpark
people saying 500 is really fair plus
you get exposure as well add a little
for gas
yeah I mean I I think we're in the 500
to slightly above based on you know uh
maybe there's a performance bonus if
it's if it's like really really
compelling
um okay so so here's the deal we're
talking about roughly 500 bucks we're
expecting you to be able to talk to
people about 45 minutes on the stream it
would probably be around seven Eastern
which is an hour before Trump speaks or
maybe even a little earlier you've got
to get there on your own and you've got
to figure out how to get get in uh and
it might Simply Be you sign up and for
people who say I don't want to do it
well but you don't you don't have to
volunteer only contact me if you want to
do it there's no reason to chat or email
me if you don't want to do it okay so if
that's interesting info davidpackman.com
and give me a sense of your setup and
what's going on and and you know we'll
we'll work it out
um and I'm not forcing anyone to do it
okay no one has to do it this is an
option this is just an option
all right Super Chat will Democrats
voters be affected by the high homicide
and crime like Republicans affected by
covid no that's that's absurd
um
that's that's no just absolutely not
okay so that's the that's the Trump
rally thing so we've gotten that done I
have so many things for you guys today
it's it's really going to be a fantastic
fantastic stream okay let's get into the
stock market and guys people asking me
to pick them in the chat you've gotta
email me and explain who you are in
order to pay you we're going to need to
know your real name you know like this
is not like it's you're not getting
hired by posting a comment
um
jeez
all right man this this stream is very
quickly going south
very very quickly going south
all right here we go
and we will ban men all right so let's
talk about the stock market the stock
market has been declining pretty
precipitously for a bit of time looking
here at the NASDAQ or As Trump used to
refer to it the NASDAQ
if you look at the last month it's been
quite a decline from close to 16
000 all the way down to about below
thirteen thousand uh so it's about two
thousand over six million what twelve
percent you know just some very very
rough math about 12
the Dow Jones Industrial Average
um peeking around close to 37k now down
to just above 34. uh so about 2700 over
37.8 percent decline okay so we're we
really have been starting to get into
where people are talking about elements
of a correction or a Slowdown of some
kind
now
um today at one point the Dow was down
some kind of completely toxic amount but
as we were getting ready to stream here
all of a sudden the markets turned
positive and we got you know about a
third of a point climb in the s p and a
third of a point in the Dow and
two-thirds of a point in the NASDAQ now
similarly with crypto we saw that for
the last month it's been a massive
massive pullback and in fact from a peak
of about 67
000 per Bitcoin down almost 50 percent
off if you can believe it so
dozens of emails people saying David
what are you doing you own stocks you
own Bitcoins what are you doing and I'm
doing absolutely nothing
I'm doing absolutely nothing and part of
why I'm doing absolutely nothing
is because of this
this is the one day on bitcoin
and then at the end of the day this is
the pretty solid day for the Dow at the
end of the day so I'm going to go
through with you guys what I tweeted
today
selling when stocks are down really
doesn't make any sense I will continue
buying without altering my asset
allocation because there's really no
other sensible option based on my age
and risk tolerance imagine even I mean
if today I said
at this time
right
oh my God we are f'd I'm getting out
I've already mistimed the market
I just in the last four hours I already
would have mistimed the market
I don't have any idea what's going to
happen now this could be what so-called
you know so-called dead cat bounce and
then tomorrow stocks go down and they
could go down you know I heard that uh
meet Kevin fafrath
was selling everything sell everything
short everything for two months
I have no idea guys what I do know is
that the more days I hold stocks and buy
stocks I'm talking about mutual funds
you know broad-based index funds
um the more I earn in dividends right if
I hold this if I hold a mutual fund 365
days as opposed to 30 I earn more in
dividends when when stock prices are
lower the dividends buy me here we go
now more shares more shares
uh and by mutual funds I want to be
clear I mean the lowest possible cost
index funds where you pay five basis
points uh I don't do mu I'm not doing
ETFs I'm I'm just doing
total Market
Index Fund five basis points that's all
I pay I'm not paying any big advisor not
paying front load backload you know
any of it okay
um I and and what really cracks me up
are the people gleefully saying all the
crypto people lost all their money we
told you they lost on all their money
first of all you sound kinda dumb when
you look at the big picture but again do
you have the right asset allocation and
even in the chat I see people laughing
about David you idiot with your Bitcoin
uh I got in here
okay
my as I've said before I've determined I
think Bitcoin is here to stay enough
that I want three to five percent of my
Assets in in the major cryptos okay
I've already sold everything I
originally invested 10 20 times over
it's all the House's money if it goes to
zero I lose three to five percent of
what I have right now
but I'm already you know 10 20 x okay so
it's just weird when people laugh about
this stuff it's like it have you chosen
the right asset allocation for a lot of
people
the right asset allocation is
you know I don't know people people
roughly roughly my age the right asset
allocation might be
five percent in crypto
15 in bonds let me actually let me make
sure this adds up to a hundred five
percent crypto
15 bonds
you know maybe some people have a lot of
real estate some don't maybe 20 in real
estate that's 40.
um and then maybe
you know even that other 60 in stocks
wouldn't be crazy probably 70 percent of
it in U.S 30 percent you know really
really simple stuff you know if that's
the right asset allocation for your risk
tolerance what are you going to do when
things go down you you shouldn't do
anything because you're in the right
asset allocation I don't know how many
times I I have to explain this to people
so anyway for everybody asking what I
did I did absolutely nothing
I did absolutely nothing I I'm I'm just
gonna keep buying and then we'll see
where we are in a year or whatever the
case may be now let's just look at some
of the responses here to my tweet
because there's a lot of just you know
fundamentally
there's a lot we Financial education in
this country is horrendous as noon wine
points out that's exactly right
um
let's see dollar cost average forever
Deepak says buy the dip I'm not actually
saying buy the dip buy the dip implies
Market timing and this is so important
for people to understand
buy the dip suggests you are
strategically holding back money that
should be allocated to stocks based on
your allocation
for a dip at which point you would say
now I'm gonna buy
I'm not advocating that because I don't
Advocate timing the market
I hope people understand that by what
I'm advocating for is if you have a plan
where on a monthly schedule you buy
you stick to the plan if you are holding
money to pick a time to buy that's
timing I don't believe I can I don't
think I'm smart enough guys
I don't think I'm smart enough to do
that so I don't do that on a schedule
that's what I'm talking about okay uh
buy Tesla do you invest in leveraged
ETFs no I use no leverage whatsoever
um
let's see what else we've got here
nothing makes me see this is one of the
dumb ones nothing makes me ha as happy
as knowing there were people that had
sell orders for Bitcoin at 69 000 and
missed it by 10 bucks and hopefully it
never recovers the emotional attachment
to these things test slides overpriced
it's bad Bitcoin it's bad it's good I
love it when people lose money in
Bitcoin or in stocks or whatever
guys pick an asset allocation and stick
with it that's it you know I I
experience no Glee or or dread
I have no attachment to these assets
whatsoever
it's uh
yeah I don't know
it could gets worse before it gets
better yeah you know all right I think
people get it that's that's uh so so
that's that's basically everything as
far as stocks go any anything else on
this
anything else on stocks I mean I feel
like I've kind of said it all
yeah I people are saying it makes them
anxious when stocks go down I'm like
sulking around the house complaining to
my girlfriend I'm not denying that
obviously I am but uh
but I know I'm in it uh in it for the
long haul I want to say thank you to
dope tipped for the twitch Prime
subscription you were number 12 today I
really appreciate that and I want to
invite you to grab a membership on my
website use the coupon code obamna
Obama to get a significant discount I
will um
I will shout out everybody who signs up
at joinpakman.com today all right let's
continue
um Richard says David check out channel
5 with Andrew Callahan if you haven't
it's basically what you're yeah they're
really really good channel five does
some good uh good interviews
for sure let's see so far
um
couple people got in touch
about going to the Trump rally okay cool
all right good let's continue Let's do
let's adjudicate some we will we will
get to um Sarah Palin has crovis we will
get to that
but before we do that I do want to
adjudicate a few whoops
a few on band requests as many of you
know my gavel is now broken it's it's
crumbling because I've been adjudicating
these unbanned requests which with such
strength
um that I I broke it
but let's see here
um a bunch of people want to be unbanned
from twitch and I'm going to make
decisions about that right now
a user named fart Brazil showed up at
one recent stream
and posted Keck W Keck W Keck W Keck W
Keck W they are waking up Joe Biden from
his nap Keck W they were banned
they then said sorry for the Keck w
.i will behave this one's pretty
borderline what do you guys think is
this a permaban or is this an unban
allow it on the basis that they Now
understand they're not allowed to do
that all right I'll adjudicate this
unbanned that's fine we'll give them
another chance
so that's that
um
next one
uh into the fury is a user who was
banned it's mostly coveted
disinformation when I spoke about a um
when I spoke about a vax I don't
remember who this was I was speaking
about a vaccinated individual who had a
case of covid
they came in and said he also had
Ivermectin this kind of raised the red
flag okay well then they said Hunter
Biden is better than Donald Trump Jr
and then said I prefer my president's
son to get a stripper pregnant while
dating his dead brother's wife
they were banned and then said why did I
get banned for preferring Hunter over
Trump Jr that's a perma-ban it's
obviously bad faith
okay next user is don't take the booster
now just on the basis of the username
ano alone it did raise a red flag just
on the basis of the username but they
were not banned on the basis of the
username
they came in and said Joe Biden is
answering scripted questions
these questions are making me want to
kill myself it's almost Joe Biden's
bedtime
they were banned
then they said Dear Mr Pacman I'm
looking at these messages I sent I have
two thoughts firstly I'm funny second
these were jokes how does this break
chat rules these moderators are very
sensitive seems you're doing well David
I would appreciate and unban what would
continue to love in your support your
channel either way
kind regards sell your Shiba Inu Jacob
from Amsterdam I'm kind of I'm willing
to unban here I think yeah I'm gonna go
with an unban
I'm feeling uh solicitous today okay and
then lastly
user Jose Stalin
showed up and said
what do Jeffrey Epstein gillain Maxwell
a and Harvey Weinstein have in common
what do jealaine Maxwell a Jeffrey
Epstein and Harvey Weinstein have in
common they are part of the tribe and
then they used triple parentheses around
the names indicating that they are all
Jewish that is I'm not even going to
look at the message that is a permaban
very very easy
and uh
we are fully adjudicated here
and ready to move on
to the next steps today
okay
I think we got it
all right before we get on to Sarah
Palin having the virus let's see what
else we got
um oh yeah speaking of the stock market
remember when Trump like when the stock
market was up he would brag and take
credit about how great the economy is
and then when the stock market was down
he just like wouldn't talk about it like
it doesn't exist
um Jen saki actually just said today to
Peter douchey
we're not basing our presidency on the
stock market at one point more than
100 points
well to start with we focus on the
trends in the economy not any one day
and any single indicator unlike his
predecessor the president does not look
at the stock market as a means by which
to judge the economy now what's funny is
at the time that this went on the Dow
was down 560 it under ended up up nearly
100 points I would note uh that the
market is up around 15 percent compared
to when President Biden took office this
is the president so anyway no no
surprises there he's continuing on
uh you may remember that former uh oh
hey welcome to everybody coming from
Jeff waldorf's twitch Channel welcome to
all 110 of you
uh great to see everybody again
we are currently talking about uh Sarah
Palin getting the virus
um Sarah Palin recently said that um
what was the exact phrase it will be
over her dead body that she gets
vaccinated she now has covid so we are
watching that case very very closely
um Sarah Palin has tested positive for
the virus which is now forcing a delay
to her defamation trial against the New
York Times here is Sarah Palin saying
over her dead body will she get the
vaccine and I will it'll be over my dead
body that I'll have to get a shot
I won't do it and um
they better not touch my kids either
because that touch my kids
that's where the well Governor some
people say though I might lose my job
I might get kicked out of school
yeah isn't Charlie Kirk a great
interviewer
then there are of them so for us to be
hesitant and for us to kind of wait for
somebody else to take this on and and
you know stand up and say you know no
enough is enough
um you need to all look around and
realize that as you stiffen your spine
okay so now she goes in even Charlie
Kirk is looking confused by the way the
size of his face and I don't I don't
really mean his head I mean like the
size of his face is bizarre
I don't even know how to I'm not even
sure I'm I'm explaining it correctly
but the key line is this one and I will
it'll be over my dead body that I'll
have to get a shot okay so Sarah Palin
now has the virus she has the virus uh
she is
57 years old
and
um
yeah so there it is she's tested
positive three times apparently
unvaccinated apparently unvaccinated
Larry says check out the black for Trump
site forget the content I challenge you
to explain the chapter title system they
use so let's see blacks for Trump
um
I can't even find the Black sport see
this is part of the problem when I
Google blacks for Trump I don't even
find a website for them does anybody
know where to find the blacks for Trump
site
I I just I'm not seeing it anywhere
blocks for Trump trends
blacks for Trump leader was in violent
cult
yeah I can't even find it
someone can email it to me it's
something I'd be willing to look up
um thank you for another great interview
interview with Mr Yanez varufacas was so
fascinating and a real eye-opener for me
I'm now reading his new book I enjoyed
the interview quite as well yeah
um
blacks for trump2020.com blocks for
trump2020.com
see what we got here
this can't possibly be real oh my God
apparently it is here's the blacks for
Trump website this is bizarre I guess
the address is limitlesstruth.com
um
oh my God
the website doesn't make any sense black
Yahweh oh my God
Yahweh Ben Yahweh
is apparently a black for Trump
yeah this is um this looks like very
very severe mental illness
look at this crazy [ __ ] this is one a
okay one cc okay so you've got part one
part one also known as one cc I'm pretty
sure I I must have malware now right
just from going to this website
then it's one cc2 okay
1A
then it's one okay
um
then we go to number two
a
three four
five or zero
um six or double zero uh I'm I think I'm
about to lose the stream guys this has
clearly infected my computer with
malware all right let's get let's get
away from it so we dealt with this we
dealt with this we dealt with this and
this very good
um okay
the level of virtue signaling put out by
their concern thereby conservatives how
many more of these anti-vaxxers need to
face serious consequences from covid
before they realize their error
unfortunately brooksie I don't know that
they will will ever realize their error
that's part of the issue
it's part of the issue thanks to F Croft
and Skittle stew for the twitch Prime
subscriptions I would love it if you
re-upped your Twitch Prime subscription
today also I would love it if you signed
up on my website joinpakman.com Johnny
Ruiz just signed up on my website and
his new member number 15 today I want to
tell you guys right now we have two
coupon code options today this is very
important and if they're spelled
incorrectly none of them work the new
2022 coupon code is wow 22.
the additional coupon code is above my
head there it's Obama oh
and this is where uh that comes from
this is these are the origins of that
if Ted doesn't win your second amendment
is going to be in trouble big trouble
remember that O'Rourke voted against the
border wall oh that's a good thing
put it against law and he voted for
Obama there it is so that is those are
the oranges of Obama and by all means
you can use that at join
pacman.com it's an oranges story as we
might call it Larry says thank you so
much hope our computers are both safe
yeah no I don't think the blacks for
Trump website really infected my
computer with malware but uh just in
case I am going to burn the computer
after the stream I want to say thanks to
stock the sky for the twitch Prime
subscription all right let's continue do
you were you guys how many of you were
with me last week for President Joe
Biden's press conference where he asked
the question what are Republicans for
and he almost even took like a kind of
whispering approach he was like what are
they for get
exactly uh were you guys with me
you were wait Biden is live right now
if he is I should pick that up let me
see if that's if that's right hold on
uh White House
I am not seeing that Biden is currently
live
oh wait he is oh my God hold on a second
Biden is live all right let's pick that
up let's let's go to that
broke you had to go to the dealer and
you had to pay the Dealer's cost the
Dealer's price
if you try to get it fixed you've tried
to fix it yourself some manufacturers
actually would void the warranty when
they sold the vehicle is this right to
repair product to you or disable the
features on that product they sold to
you denying the right to repair raises
prices for consumers means independent
repair shops can't compete for your
business and my experiment my executive
order announced that support for the
right to repair rather right after I
issued my order I was pleased to see the
Federal Trade Commission unanimously
announced it would ramp up unanimously
announcement ramp up enforcement against
illegal repair restrictions not a joke
that was allowed by major companies uh
to or by voluntarily agreeing to change
their restrictions on repairs
um and especially and what's happened
was a lot of these companies said you're
right we're going to voluntarily do it
you don't have to order us to do it and
voluntarily said we'll do it for example
apple and Microsoft are changing their
policies so folks will be able to repair
their phones and laptops themselves
although I'm not sure I know how to do
that uh
I am when I have any problem my phone I
call my daughter with all due respect
that's a bunch of it's going to make it
easier for millions of Americans to
repair their electronics instead of
paying an arm and a leg to repair or
just throwing the device out
hearing aids roughly 48 million people
suffer from hearing loss in America 48
million but to get a hearing aid folks
have to get go see a specialist and then
get a prescription
and then they pay thousands of dollars
for a pair of hearing aids but the big
part is why only that's a big part of
only one in five people who will he
introduce Mike pillow who will be
manufacturing hearing aids today
competition executive order changes that
in October the Food and Drug
Administration released a new proposal
rule that would make it possible for
hearing aids to be sold over the counter
without a prescription
we expect this is going to lower cost
for hearing aids from thousands of
dollars to literally to hundreds of
dollars saving people's hundreds and
hundreds of dollars
and and people will can pick them up at
a local pharmacy saving time and money
and helping the tens of million people
with hearing loss who don't have hearing
aids now
third area mergers
in too many Industries big companies big
companies can use their power to squeeze
out smaller competitors stifle new
competition raise prices reduce the
choice for customers and exploit their
workers well I've said it before
capitalism without competition is is not
capitalism
so the Department of Justice and other
agencies with oversight Authority have
ramped up their efforts to scrutinize
these mergers
it includes challenging or blocking
mergers that are bad for the economy and
your pocketbooks for example the
Department of Justice just took action
to block a mega merger that would have
resulted in two brokerages dominating
the insurance industry which would
result in customers having fewer choices
higher prices and lower quality services
the bottom line this isn't just about
quick wins it's about reversing Decades
of concentration that have hurt workers
consumers and small businesses it didn't
happen any one time it's been over a
period of time now a long time
this is just the beginning though in the
coming weeks and months Americans can
expect to see more more protections for
farmers and ranchers selling products
like beef pork and poultry more options
and better prices for consumers
more clarity in the actual price you'll
pay for high-speed internet services and
airline tickets
we're also going to keep pushing on
other priorities and from my executive
order like addressing the non-compete
clauses that affect one in five workers
one in five workers have to sign a
non-compete Clause it stunned me that's
how this as Brian will this how this
came about really this whole competitive
Council I knew what was going on when I
realized how many people out there with
no special insight to having access to
patents or anything else had to sign a
non-compete Clause people making hourly
wages
all designed to keep prices down for to
keep wages down and prices up but one in
five workers had to give and gave them
the company the power over their careers
the bottom line is our economy should be
about people working for capitalism it
should be about capitalism working for
people for everyone now I'm going to
turn this over to Brian so we can get
this meeting started but again thank
each and every one of you here on this
Council I really mean we may not take
this whole thing because I have so much
to go over with you guys to do this
Council some of you you all thought is a
good idea but I'll be I'm I'll be
surprised if some of you didn't go whoa
I didn't realize how restrictive some of
this was
how respective some of this was but
you're going to make a difference in
ordinary people's lives ordinary
people's lives are going to make a
difference so anyway Brian the floor is
yours
oh my God okay
we're gonna bail on this so Joe Biden is
doing things and he is the president and
he will sign various different elements
good we have so much to talk about that
I'm gonna I'm gonna get back to it uh
hold on and we will be and Men there we
go so now
Joni Ernst here we're bailing out yeah
Joni Ernst was given the opportunity to
prove Joe Biden wrong
she was asked by Jake Tapper
all right Joe Biden said you guys aren't
for anything
give me three things
give me three things Republicans would
do
if you took control
in November
I don't think any of you can imagine how
disastrous her answer was okay take a
look at this
so Senate uh minority leader Mitch
McConnell has said he does not feel that
uh Republicans need to present an agenda
to the country
um and generally speaking I understand
the politics midterms tend to be
referenda on the people who are running
the country but what are three things
that Republicans will do uh if you
recapture the senate in the midterms so
what are three things you will do okay
the question is very clear here we go
well I think that Republicans stand for
a strong free and prosperous nation and
it's already insane it's already insane
all right now fair enough
she's just laying out the framework they
stand for a free prosperous Nation now
she's gonna tell us the things she's
gonna do and so uh one we need to tackle
the issue of inflation Biden is facing a
40-year high with the inflation rate and
Iowans and all Americans are feeling
those pressures so alleviating those
pressures on our families would be a job
number one coach so so the first thing
they'll do is they're going to deal with
inflation
is that a policy how would you do it we
think inflation is too high and we will
lower it oh I
didn't realize it was so simple just
good but now by the set with due respect
Center
could could you tell us how will you use
uh monetary policy or what what exactly
they'll just lower it over they will
also ban the virus right I mean it's
like we're basically talking about the
same type of thing here so the first
thing is they're going to deal with
inflation how we don't know second
policy elevated as well we need to make
sure that American families have access
to testing by the way hearing her say
now we need dusting but certainly we
want to make sure that they are getting
their children back into school and that
their workplaces where does that accent
children children
are safe and they can return to work
basically every school and employer is
open there are some schools that are
remote some that were open but all the
teachers got covered so they had to
close but like what what is what is the
policy that she's outlining here so
that's the second thing the first thing
is they will lower inflation doesn't say
how
second one is they're going to get
schools and workplaces open they're
basically all open
and what's her third thing um and then
as well we need to to focus on uh
additional things like uh you know
foreign relations with our allies
because we're going to do foreign
relations with our allies guys that's
the platform is it I mean come on why
would they're gonna do the thing they're
going to lower inflation and open
schools and workplaces and they're going
to do Foreign Relations that's that's
what it is
so okay I'll play the rest yes obviously
with National Security we are under a
lot of pressure right now so Republicans
believe in peace through strength I
certainly believe that by the way these
are all problems they caused which now
she says she's going to solve without
actually saying how or at least they
were part they were part of the problems
let's be a little more fair so Joe Biden
was right they have absolutely no idea
what they stand for they probably don't
stand for anything they probably don't
stand for anything
um I want to say thanks to Dylan
McClanahan who just signed up at
joinpakman.com and his new member number
17 today
also want to say thank you to the
following people for signing up via
twitch Prime which is free if you have
Amazon Prime stock the sky snowy Shady
nights irie man and Pizza Man DRC that's
five putting us at 22.
and I really appreciate that
what are your thoughts of uh many of the
alt-right and Progressive movements both
on the side of Russia with the Ukraine
standoff issue well I've addressed this
already there's different reasons why
some on the left and some on the right
seem to love Russia now
um but I I have addressed that isn't
Joni Ernst the same Republican Party
of fiscal responsibility senator who
didn't know the price of corn in her own
State yes
exactly
Charlie Kirk's face is so bizarre
there's a game someone made online if
you Google Charlie Kirk face all right
let's not do that right now but it is
something that that we can look at okay
here's a woman who went to
um the school board meeting in Virginia
where her kid or kids go to school she
said if my kids have to wear a mask I
will show up with my loaded guns on
Monday she was arrested and charged no
mask mandates my child my children will
not come to school on Monday with a mask
on now bear in mind Glenn youngin has
already passed something I think
Executive Order in Virginia which allows
parents to opt their kids out of mask
requirements so like this is all
completely unnecessary but check out
what she says all right that's not
happening and I will bring every single
gun loaded and ready to I I will call
every that's three minutes if you come
past your path it's a policy thank you
I'll see you all on Monday
she's been arrested she was released on
five thousand dollars Bond
um and she says she didn't mean she
didn't literally mean guns
right so when she said
I will bring each of my guns loaded on
Monday and then said see y'all on Monday
she didn't mean with literal guns she
met with
I don't know what else I don't know what
what else you could mean by my loaded
guns
she yeah right she meant her biceps
exactly that's exactly what she meant uh
so she's been arrested and that's really
good news but she is out on bond
here's Tucker Carlson apparently Tucker
Carlson used to be really turned on by
anthropomorphized candy and he's getting
very upset the latest battle in the
culture war is that the brown m m will
have shorter high heels and Tucker is no
longer turned on by it and this is part
of the cancel culture
thing that
everybody's doing okay let's listen
finally
finally gives story tips to NPR but
here's a story they might want to cover
pretty soon in doubt as well maybe maybe
M M's the candy company it's just
announced that it's redesigning its
cartoon characters to be more gender
inclusive
[Music]
bravely on the Vanguard of the culture
War
[Music]
thank you
bet she didn't think
Eminem's were pushing intolerance but
they were they've been changed you're
seeing the changes right now on your
screen the green Eminem you will notice
is no longer wearing sexy boots now
she's wearing sensible sneakers why the
change well according to Eminem's quote
we all win when we see more women in
leading roles because leading women do
not wear sexy boots leading women to
wear frumpy shoes the frumpier the
better that's the rule right the other
big change is that the brown m m has
quote transitioned from high stilettos
to lower block heels Brown was always
the big turn-on for Tucker apparently
also less sexy that's progress M M's
will not be satisfied until every last
cartoon character is deeply unappealing
and totally androgynous until the moment
you wouldn't want to have a drink with
any one of them that's the goal when
you're totally turned off
we've achieved Equity they've won
meanwhile in a nod to the burgeoning
wellness movement the orange m m will
quote acknowledge and embrace his
anxiety that's kind of just I mean this
is also stupid
um but it's also weird
for Tucker to be doing this
and actually if you look at him the
orange m m does appear very anxious
maybe he doesn't like all the ugly new
shoes he sees around him maybe he liked
the sexy boots right maybe the orange m
m is a secret sexist himself
we don't know we're gonna let not being
turned on by anthropomorphized candy is
basically stalinist leninism that's I
mean I'm willing to say it I you know
you guys disagree with me but uh I think
that that's basically where we are at
this point in time I don't think there's
any other possible interpretation of
this I want to say thank you to Elliot
Broach who just made a pledge on patreon
we're counting those double today so
that'll put us at 24.
also want to say thank you to Cipher
drag for the twitch Prime subscription I
really appreciate that as well
um all right so you know I did I
recorded a segment on this for today's
podcast so I won't say too too much
about it let me see what else I've got
um oh okay for those who follow me on
Instagram first of all you might have
seen me the other day holding a Buddha's
hand this is a citrus fruit I candied it
using the the Jacques Pepin
candying citrus fruit recipe and it came
out absolutely perfect it's big I
thought it was like a fruit that you
could eat it turns out it's basically
all pith
so I ended up candying it along with
orange skin and lime and stuff like that
pretty good and I encourage people to
check out the Jacques Pepe recipe for
that but more importantly if you follow
me on Instagram
in response to my segment today about a
Bobby Kennedy Jr going uh uh going
Holocaust trivializer at yesterday's
anti-vaxx rally
this was a response we got and I I don't
know how the show will recover to the
bite from this Dr Stone wrote hi hey
David is it possible your y-o-u-r the
one disconnected from reality you listed
Afghanistan as Biden's accomplishment
and think the Derek chalvin trial
supports the big lie the police killed
him
we may be pulled off the air for months
as we seek to recover from this
um
yeah
so anyway clearly a troubled individual
and I would uh if you if if you were
following me on Instagram at
david.pakman you would have known about
that
some time ago
some time ago
all right so let's get rid of this
oh this is cool a friend of mine posted
this this is a great sort of cultural
history moment this is Katie Couric
um is this Bryant Gumbel I don't know
which Gumble it or no this is Greg
Gumbel right I know that there's
Brothers I'm not super familiar with
them is this Greg Gumbel
anybody know
Katie Couric
Bryant Gumbel this is Bryant Gumbel and
who is this does anybody know who this
is
that Ann Curry I don't even know
the woman on the right guys the woman on
the right
okay nobody knows who that is all right
here they are trying to figure out
what's going on with this internet thing
this is from
1994. okay let's take a listen that's a
56 pass I wasn't prepared to translate
that as I was doing that little tease oh
that little Mark with the A and then the
ring around it at see that's what I said
um Katie said she thought it was about
yeah oh but I've never heard it around
I've never heard it said I'd always seen
the mark but never heard it said and
then it sounded stupid what I said it
violence at NBC
there it is violence at NBC GE com I
mean right
anyway
internet is uh that massive computer
network the one that's becoming really
big now isn't this the best this is this
is absolutely the best what do you mean
how does one what do you write to it
like mail no a lot of people use it and
communicate I guess they can communicate
with NBC writers and producers Allison
can you explain what internet is no she
can't say anything in 10 seconds or less
Allison will be in the studio shortly
what does it mean giant computer network
made up made up of uh started from this
is like a Jamie could you pull that up
for me please some guy off camera
explains what an internet is Oh I
thought you were gonna tell us what this
was
it's it's a computer billboard but it's
like it's several uh universities and
everything all joined together right and
others can access it right and it's
getting bigger and bigger all the time
so it came in really handy during the
Quake a lot of people that's how they
were communicating out to tell family
and loved ones they were okay they were
using an internet because all the phone
lines were down I was telling Katie you
know you don't need you don't need that
you don't need a phone line to operate
no no well at the time you kind of did
right I mean is that even true you kind
of dude anyway okay so this remind me
this reminded me of the very strange
telemarketer call I got where a guy said
he was using an internet and this it was
a classic David Pacman show moment
here's one for the some of the kids in
the audience
love this
yeah
we have a whole story behind it
hello hello
somebody speaking with the business
owner yes you are yes somebody speaking
with the business owner yes you are yes
from the local business services so sir
this is just a quick call do you accept
credit cards in your business uh from
who
I'm sorry do we do you accept credit
card from your business this is from the
early days of the internet that's the
more the payment uh sometimes we do yeah
how did you get my number
okay
um we're calling all the businesses in
the United States
and which business Which business are
you calling credit card
yes we do yes I'm calling from the local
yes I'm calling from the local business
services
we accept all of them
Uh Oh I thought your name was so are we
on a delay sir yes I am the
I'm sorry it sounds like we're on a bit
of a delay
I'm sorry sir
how can I how can I help you
okay would you be interested in finding
our topic again and ask the cash or
capital for your business I would I just
need to know credit score guarantee I
would be very interested but first I
just need to know where you got my
number
okay
um recording from the local business
services and we're um calling all the
businesses no I can't I can't understand
I understand where you're calling from
but how did you get my phone number
phone number okay um in other words
all the businesses yes so my question is
how did you know what number to dial to
get me
okay sir were using an internet
[Laughter]
anyway that's the moment I was looking
for we're using an internet is what the
Katie Couric uh
video video reminded me of I guess we'll
just listen to the last few seconds here
just very confused if if I would be glad
to buy 10 of what you're selling if you
could tell me how you got my number
yes sir we're we're going all the
businesses from the
unit okay and how did they get it in
other words what list is my number on
I'm sorry okay
I'd like to this is one of my favorite
favorite moments where like with some of
these scammers they couldn't scam you if
they tried because there's no way to buy
what they're offering like with a lot of
these you you deliberately try to fall
for it and you you literally can't be
scammed because they can't finish the
scam like I'm trying to get scammed and
he won't let me move along with the
purchase and buy 10 of what you're
selling so tell me how can I buy what
you're selling me
okay would you be interested
very interested okay then how
okay then how about they're reducing
your credit card trusting fees and save
hundreds and thousands I can save
thousands would you like to receive it
yes okay I'll take it thousands of
dollars will be reducing the credit card
processing fees okay
we're about to go live so I'm gonna have
to let you go but please do call me back
thank you okay anyway so
it didn't it didn't go anywhere
um
but it was like I couldn't possibly get
scammed because he was unable to sell me
anything I think there's another one
where a guy said something about like my
wife let me see the IRS yeah this guy
hung up on me this was another one check
this one out
we used to get all these calls all the
time this is really bringing back
memories from the early days of the show
uh I think you'll like this one
with this one I was here we go
hello hello
yes hi my name's calling with Visa
MasterCard merchant services how are you
today I'm doing well
that's good that's good
um the reason I called is to see if your
business is currently accepting debit
and credit cards as a form of payment
um we are not currently doing that now
okay because uh uh Visa Mastercard has
pre-approved your business to start
accepting debit and credit cards oh how
did you get our information
well we actually get it from the Chamber
of Commerce oh we're not members of any
Chamber of Commerce oh well did you did
you just get a new telephone listing
then yes we just got a new phone line
and that's what it is we got it and
that's how we got your your uh company
information so when you said you got it
from the chamber that wasn't true right
well no we do get information from the
Chamber of Commerce as well but how
would the chamber have our number if
we're not members
look if you want to argue do you do that
with your wife there's one of this one
or several ways we can get the
information I'm sorry what was your name
oh man and then he hangs up I just love
that man that is just I I these though
these were the days guys
um man that guy did not like that
trying to think if there's any if
there's any there's the IRS one
uh
uh I don't even remember the
telemarketer calls me I offer debt
relief
I don't even remember that let's check
that out oh we might be getting the
telemarketer call ladies and gentlemen
let me pause here if we do this is going
to be two in a row I don't this one I
have no memory of I think it's fantastic
is it I'm trying to see Lewis is talking
to someone now how are we getting this
lucky
Louis not uh is a thumbs up or down
it doesn't appear to be a good situation
Lewis in the background oh we're getting
a thumbs up ladies and gentlemen I can't
believe we're getting this lucky with
these calls all right Lewis come on and
give us the premise I can't believe this
is happening again no no your mic's off
it's like exactly the same as the other
person here we go you ready
we had a strict policy where no matter
what we were doing if a telemarketer
called in
um we would stop all all recording and
just talk to the telemarketer hello
yes hello Mr Speaker the owner the
manager please is this him yes I'm the
manager hello uh hi sir good afternoon
um this is and uh I'm calling from
we're just calling sir to let you know
that your business will be featured as
the most recommended business for
Northampton next month oh this is when
we were based in Northampton yeah well
we just want to make sure your business
information that we have here is still
correct and up-to-date uh there would be
no cost for this year for being the
future business next month and how did
you get my number
oh well
um we currently have your uh basic uh
information with us sir and where did
you get because you called me how did
you find my phone number
um uh once that you have registered as a
business on your local area you're
automatically listed in our online
business listing uh this is for your
business listing which appears on
google.com meow.com being an AOL you
know I've actually I have heard of the
Google
yeah hey let me ask you a question would
you be interested in debt relief
services because I actually offer we're
able to do an analysis of all of your
debt situation and see we might be able
to save you hundreds and thousands of
dollars on your monthly credit card
bills would you be interested in that
oh sure why not well you would be
interested in that let me confirm your
details here hold on one second uh okay
sure very good so there's a small
administrative fee for this it's 25 per
month and we'll go through and do a full
audit of all your credit card bills and
we'll be able to consolidate payments
does that sound good
hello
oh man that's a pretty good one too
all right I think that those are all the
telemarketing calls we've done
uh
uh oh no here's another one all right
Let's do let's do one more are we okay
with just one more of these I want to
see let's let's find just one more
uh I'm here I'm these are like new to me
because I just don't remember them oh
well we're getting a phone call should I
get this it could be a telemarketer uh
all right well we'll stand by and see
all right but answer it off Lewis now
I'll play by play Lewis picking up the
phone saying hello David packman show we
may have a live one here we may have a
live telemarketer and if we do we will
switch over to that yes um because you
know as we know we actually we may have
a live one dude Lewis is giving me the
thumbs up so let's stand by
let's stand by here and see if we can
actually get this one okay hold on a
second Louis come on and tell me what
the premise is here
she just wants to talk to the owner of
the business so here we go ladies and
gentlemen this is happening live here we
go do we want to get are we trying to
get the camera going no we don't need to
just record it okay ready here we go
hello
hi am I speaking with the owner or the
manager of the business yes you are
great hi good afternoon my name is
very good I've been texting you in
regard to your business listing which
appears in Google Yahoo Bing and AOL and
yeah to let you know we're calling to
make you the featured business for
Northam Northampton next month that is
why we need to make sure your
information is up to date ahead of time
so at least if we don't have top
placement on Bing I don't even know that
we could have a show you can probably
display your test okay wait a second so
we've been chosen as the featured
business you're telling me on the Google
actually not this in Google it goes with
Yahoo Bing and AOL and also 100 more
search engines and directories can you
list the 100 search engines for me
I'm sorry I would can you just give me
the list of those hundred search engines
just so I can write them down
AOL Amazon and uh local listing Pages
those are just some of the more than 100
search engines and this all happens on
an internet right
yeah it's online business listing it's a
form of an advertisement for your
business of course I just want to be
sure do you guys in your opinion
internets are serious business right
because I need to be sure I'm doing
business with people who believe okay
yeah of course just to let you know 87
of consumers are looking for products
and services online so how can we be
featured um in other words we have a
very uh particular business not
everything that we do is completely
legal we're involved in a lot of drug
prostitution Etc we can we still be
featured on the Google on this very
serious internet that you work with
you will have statistics that I'm sorry
for the inconvenience thank you very
much and have a great day
okay so that was that was just a that
was a bridge too far for her
um that really wrapped quickly
okay all right so anyway let's let's
move on but that uh I guess that's a no
we can't be listed if we're dealing with
those projects products
it was in a legal business
um honestly if they couldn't get me at
the top of Ask Jeeves I wasn't gonna buy
it no matter what that's that's the
truth of the matter all right I want to
say thank you to David Claxton who just
signed up on my website using the coupon
code and his new member number 26 also
want to say thanks to minute
trafula trees for gifting five subs and
signing up that's seven total
and Cipher drag is eight
putting us at 34.
I appreciate that very very much all
right let's get off of that
we did this we did that
um oh yeah a couple people wrote in and
there was like a a Reddit thread saying
I should try geoguesser
and I kind of I played a couple rounds
over the weekend it's actually kind of
interesting so I thought maybe I would
play a round of geoguessr right now and
we'll just see if this is even remotely
entertaining so I think if I do the
classic that's the whole world right
that's because you can do also a us only
one
let's try it okay here we go
geoguessr oh okay world all right let's
play here's world and we're gonna play
so we have to try to figure out where we
are in the world let's see here
um okay
so
this looks very American to me right off
the bat
uh usually things are blurred there's
pretty big
uh everything about this looks like the
United States
let's see if we can move around I don't
even really know like what to look for
this van is typical of the United States
could be Canada as well
let's see
this person is not
hmm
I mean I hate to say it but because of
the obesity rate in the U.S and Mexico
when you see obesity a lot of obesity
you can you can start to narrow down
that it could be the U.S clearly this is
not Mexico but I don't know that that
really tells us too too much looking at
that
um
I guess you really can't go by the
license plates because they're blurred
obviously that would be too easy
hmm let's see if we can go
okay this is an American Sign okay so it
is the United States we've narrowed that
down this is this no parking fire lane
sign correct me if I'm wrong guys that
is only in the United States they don't
have that exact sign is that fair
okay very good
what other indicators might there be I
think if we saw some flags on houses
that would be a sign too
this looks like the type of neighborhood
where you would see Flags
but I'm not seeing it
hmm
all right the stop sign I mean it it's
got to be this has to be the U.S or
Canada I think
it's extremely flat here
hold on let me see if I can reduce the
size of that and there we go
it's quite flat I mean so far I'm
thinking it's it's probably the northern
half of the U.S let's see what this
building is
ah it's an American flag okay
Northwest so it's the United States
Northwest I can't quite see what that
says
but it is the United States so that
certainly does narrow it down
um
that's Northwest University that's what
that is
I can't see what that is
let's see if we can get somewhere that
might okay hold on is this one of those
pods no it's just a dumpster
hmm
it doesn't look like the actual
Northwest of the United States that's
the only thing
yeah like Midwest seems more likely
let's just see if we can get
to the end of the street or let's see if
the trash can has any signs on it
no
hmm like to some degree I'm not even
sure what else I should be looking for
sometimes you end up downtown like let's
just keep going we're going west right
now let's just keep see if we can get to
the end of the street oh and now it
turns
to the South
hmm
I only have 90 seconds left I understand
so right now I'm thinking like this
could be Illinois Ohio Missouri
something like that
um
a store can be useful yeah I don't know
I've got one minute left
oh I don't know that's kind of looking
like maybe it's a blurred Illinois plate
it's just like we're in the middle of
nowhere I wish we could get to a town
we're definitely running low on time
when we get to 30 seconds I'm gonna pick
a spot
yeah I don't know that we're getting
anywhere
all right so here's the deal
tell me what you guys think I'm kind of
thinking somewhere in here Illinois
Indiana it's Central Illinois
the fencing is old school maybe Ohio
oh man I don't know I think I might just
go
I might just go right in the middle of
Indiana and split the difference that
it's between Illinois and Ohio let's
just try it I'm gonna guess okay
oh it's very close to Cincinnati that's
not bad
169 kilometers from the correct location
that's really not bad
that's really not bad that I mean is
that considered good I've never played
this before
is 170 kilometers okay
it's terrible oh okay
that's too bad
okay
all right good thanks to our Cobb densk
for gifting 10 Subs as well as mug of
atmosphere Lucan and dynamic that puts
us at 47. I appreciate that yeah I'll do
I'll do another round oh thank you also
to Margaret Gayton for signing up on my
website with the coupon code Obama
um you are number 48 today very very
much appreciate that one more round yeah
I'll do it let's go let's go play next
round
um
oh I don't have a free account I don't
have a free I don't have a paid account
I didn't even know you needed one
um
I don't even know I'm not gonna sign up
I mean I would I have no problem paying
but I'm not going to take the time to
sign up is there some other way we can
do this or is there some other free one
I'll I'll pull it up
let me see here
Geo guesser
uh
uh oh okay hold on
this game is free I found a free is this
this is the same thing I guess
anybody know what we're looking at here
let's take a look at this sign
Okay so
we're talking about Spanish here right
ah so this says root to the Atlantic
400 meters you can reverse Direction
that's important
that's important okay
let's see what we can find out about
this one
we seem to be like on this car this is
weird
let's see what the school bus says
okay Community the rest seems blurred so
I think generally speaking I think we
are sort of from Mexico South
uh and somewhere on the Atlantic coast
because it says to get to the Atlantic
reverse Direction
um oh wait but we're pointed East that's
interesting
see what else we can find here
this one is very very interesting
so it's a wood store maderas
all right
let's see what else we can find here
Fourth Avenue
hmm
so it's I'm thinking Latin America
somewhere near the Atlantic coast I
don't believe it's Brazil because the
sign I think was in Spanish
uh let's see what we've got oh oh oh oh
hold on a second this is big
so 23 29 that that's local currency
presumably per liter says
meaning you can trust them
it's a pleasure to serve you
hmm
so we if the currency that it re that I
don't I'm not really gleaning anything
from the currency it's obviously per
liter if it said like 10 000 per liter
we could say it's Argentina because of
the cartoonish inflation let's see what
else we've got here
hmm
yeah I'm not seeing
see where else we can get
Mexico has privatized gas so it's not
Mexico that's interesting oh I can't it
does can I still keep going yeah here we
go the controls are absolutely toxic
here I'm not gonna lie see what this is
very difficult to see these things
I wish I oh I can use the uh
what's this
no that's not really giving us any hints
okay let's see what this sign is
Valencia
so this number actually is a plausible
Argentinian number
Valencia
wow that that's got to be a hint
RIS
electrical
wow so we've got four minutes left four
minutes
wow uh
it's not totally implausible like it
could be Argentina
Pintura Corona
I don't know it's just not it's not
really feeling like Argentina to me
obviously if there was an unblurred
license plate we still got four minutes
yeah so so
these signs oh no we don't want to go
that way hold on a second
oh where am I
I gotta get back on that main road ah
here it is
hmm anybody have a strong feeling I'm
I'm certainly ready to rule out Mexico
it's just not really looking like
Argentina I don't know
hmm
Panama
some people sing Panama
this
I think I'm saying it's not Argentina
we still got three minutes let's see if
we can glean some additional information
you know the only thing that makes me
think Argentina is Argentina has these
black license plates with with I believe
it's white lettering
and that looks like it could be a
blurred black license plate that's the
only oh wait a second hold on
that is not an Argentinian license plate
that is not an Argentinian license plate
yeah I'm thinking
Pepsi jumbo
hmm I have time to find like maybe one
or two more clues
but we are sort of getting to the end
here
wow this is this is very very tough
all right I'm going to go into the
guessing area so I am ruling out Mexico
it's just not feeling like Mexico
but it could be I think Panama is
plausible
Honduras
could it be the Dr guys I don't think
it's Colombia because it said path to
the Atlantic
so I don't think it's Colombia because
Colombia as you can see here is is on
the west
so it doesn't doesn't really make sense
Central America yeah I think I'm going
in with Central America
hold on can I move this thing
oh God I can see that it's kind of off
there we go I'm I think I'm gonna go
Central America
Venezuela Panama man this is I it's just
really a shot in the dark I'm gonna go
Panama yeah let's go I'm just gonna go
right uh I don't know if it's on the
let's just go like here
I'm just guessing Okay this is just a
guess let's take a look
it was Guatemala okay listen no not
terrible we were in the area
I guess when it said path to the
Atlantic it was very very far but a lot
of people were saying Guatemala a lot of
people were saying Guatemala well done
well done for everybody who did
excellent all right so that's Geo
guesser that's geoguesser maybe we'll do
it again at some point in time all right
just a couple of other quick things
um Judge Andrew Napolitano if I recall
correctly oh no it says here Judge
Andrew Napolitano has slowly resurfaced
on Fringe right cable
uh and here he is today he looks
terrible look at this
he he looks absolutely terrible I hope
he's not sick
but he looks really really really bad
so we send our best to Judge Andrew
Napolitano
and I'm told there's a few super chats
to look at let me see here our Super
Chat system is not functioning as it
should be so we kind of like can't go
back unfortunately yeah I apologize I
can't get back to the super chats
because the system is completely toxic
right now
Biden caught on hot Mike about Ducey
let's see if we can find that oh wait
before we do that so check this out this
is a q Anon Trump person who now has
coveted they were at the rally last
Saturday and now they have coven day
five of this nasty virus but I have to
say Therapeutics are a godsend oh
they're working
so out of the belly of the Beast but
this too shall pass as I've been telling
my friends like bad gas oh my God so
that's uh yep that's going on and then
let's see
Biden Ducey hot Mike
let's see if we can find that
Biden calls Peter Ducey a stupid son of
a [ __ ] oh this I have to hear hold on a
second
that's a great asset more inflation
what a stupid son of a [ __ ] guys I
don't know that that's really a hot mic
I don't think he cares I don't know that
that's even a hot mic
like he's he's literally in front of the
mic
man that's pretty solid I like that
it's pretty strong
that's a great asset more inflation
what a stupid son of a bit
and we will ban men
um
yeah I don't uh I don't know that we can
say hot Mike because it just sounds like
he's just reacting to it let's see let
me let me respond to it
it's not clear this is a hot
oh wait a second
hot mic moment
ums Biden seems like he knows he's on
mic makes it far more interesting
I like that let's listen one more
that's a great asset more inflation
what a stupid son of a [ __ ] so we need
that drop we need that audio drop
absolutely must be added to the sound
board uh yes with without question
without question I want to say thanks to
GD cardi and dirty Curda
for the twitch Prime subscriptions
numbers 49 and 50. that is going to do
it for me today we will get the stupid
son of a [ __ ] comment on the sound
board in time for the next stream I may
see everybody tomorrow and remember that
we'll be here Saturday uh for the Trump
rally so thanks everybody for joining me
we'll see you very soon